armed guards escorted separatist leader
alexander zakharchenko to the polls the
outcome was assured he has solidified
his position as head of the
self-proclaimed People's Republic of
Donetsk the government in Kyiv must
recognize our Republic and return our
territory only then will there be normal
relations with Ukraine there were no
figures on voter turnout although
polling stations appeared to be full
throughout the day as the initial
results rolled in it became clear that
zakharchenko had no real opposition most
of those loyal to the Kiev government
had long since fled Donetsk and Luhansk
no independent observers from the EU or
OSCE were present to confirm the result
we want peace and kindness in our
Republic and we want to reliable
government that will help us that's why
I'm here all the candidates are good so
we will vote for them I want Don best to
be free without war then bust oliso
aboard in ukrainian President Petro
poroshenko rejected the elections as a
farce unconstitutional and in violation
of international law Western leaders in
Brussels and Washington agree the vote
threatens to further destabilize the
region we have opened a criminal case
against the separatists for trying to
form an unconstitutional state authority
we believe the rebels are preparing for
armed conflict in Luhansk Regina lado I
was a hopeless Russian convoys with
humanitarian aid signs crossed the
border into Donetsk Sunday morning
Ukrainian security officials have
repeatedly accused Moscow of arming the
rebels Russia denies the claims but says
it will recognize the vote
you